where we left off in the last video we
had come up with an expression as a
function of x of our combined area based
on where we make the cut and now we just
need to figure out where this hits a
minimum value and to do that we just
have to take we just have to take the
derivative of this business figure out
where our derivative is either undefined
or zero and then just make sure that
that is a minimum value and then we'll
be all set
so let me rewrite this so our our
combined area our combined area as a
function of x let me just rewrite this
so it's a little bit easier to take the
derivative so this is going to be the
square root of 3
times x squared over let's see this is 4
times 9. this is x squared over 9. so
this is going to be 4 times 9 is 36 and
then over here in blue this is going to
be plus
minus x squared over
16. now let's take the derivative of
this
so a prime our combined area
the derivative of our combined area as a
function of x is going to be equal to
well the derivative of this with respect
to x is just going to be
square root of 3 x over
18.
the derivative of this with respect to x
was the derivative of something squared
over 16 with respect to that something
so that's going to be
that something
something to the first power times 2
over 16 which is just over 8
and then times which is doing the chain
rule times the derivative of the
something with respect to x the
derivative of 100 minus x with respect
to x is just negative 1. so times times
negative 1 times so we'll multiply
negative 1 right over here and so we can
rewrite all of that as
this is going to be equal to the square
root of 3
over 18
x
plus
plus let's see i could write this as
positive x over eight so i could write
this as
1 8 x right because negative 1 times a
negative x is positive x over 8 and then
minus 100 over 8 which is negative 12.5
minus
12.5 and we want to figure out an x that
minimizes this area so let's this this
derivative right over here is defined
for any x so we're not going to get our
critical point by figuring out where the
derivative is undefined but we might get
a critical point by setting this
derivative equal to zero to figure out
what x values make our derivative zero
when do we have a zero slope for our
original function and then we just have
to verify that this is going to be a
minimum point if we can find an x it
makes this thing equal to zero so let's
try to solve for x so if we add 12.5 to
both sides we get
12.5 is equal to if you add the x terms
you get square root of 3
over eighteen
plus one eighth
x to solve for x divide both sides by
this business you get x is equal to
twelve point five
over square root of three over eighteen
plus
one over eight
and we are done at x equals this our
derivative is equal to zero now we know
i shouldn't say we're done yet we don't
know whether this is a minimum point in
order to figure out whether this is a
minimum point we have to figure out
whether our our function is concave
upward or concave downward when x is
equal to this business and to figure
that out let's take the second
derivative here
so the second derivative so let me
rewrite the second derivative of all of
this business
the second derivative well this this was
the same function as this right over
here so let me write it rewrite it so a
prime the derivative of our combined
area is equal to the square root of 3
over 18 x plus 1 8 x minus 12.5 the
second derivative the second derivative
is going to be square root of 3 over 18
plus 1 over 8. so this thing right over
here is greater than zero which means
we're concave upward for all x's
concave
concave upwards which means for all x's
we're kind of doing a situation like
this so if we find an x where the slope
is zero
it's going to be over an interval where
it's concave upwards this is concave
upwards for all x so we're going to be
we're going to be at a minimum point the
slope is zero right over here this right
over here will be a minimum point so
once again this is going to be a minimum
point now if we actually had 100 meter
wire
this expression isn't too valuable we'd
want to get a pretty close approximation
in terms of where to actually make the
cut an actual decimal number so let's
use a calculator to get that
so we have 12.5
divided by
square root of 3
divided by 18
plus
1 divided by 8. 1 divided by 8
gives us and now we deserve our drum
roll this is
56.5
so this is approximately equal to
approximately equal to 56
56.5 meters so you make
you make this cut
56 roughly 56.5 all right roughly i'll
make it little 56.5 meters from the left
hand side and you will minimize the
combined area of both of these figures